this is the press previewer first look
at the newspapers
as they arrive and in the next half hour
we'll talk through those headlines with
the
the author and journalist rachel shabby
and the lead writer at the daily
telegraph
tim stanley good to see you both this
evening before we have a chat
let's run you through the front pages
should we we'll start with the sunday
times
it says all school children will be back
in the classroom on the 8th of march
with the prime minister
expected to set out a lockdown exit
strategy in the coming weeks the sunday
telegraph says
adults will be given some small freedoms
on the same date including picnics and
coffee in the park the mail on sunday
meanwhile says lockdown will end by
easter with people free to drink in beer
gardens and
dine outside restaurants once again
the sunday express leads with demands
that the third lockdown in england
should be the last one it says a
powerful group of tory mps has told the
prime minister
to lift all restrictions by may
the observer carries claims from a
leading scientist that the uk repeatedly
failed to heed early warnings about the
virus as the government looks set to
achieve its vaccination target
scotland on sunday reports that the
number of people catching coved in
hospital is at a record high
and the daily star sunday claims the
army is killing
hundreds of dogs instead of re-homing
them when they
retire from service
okay let's talk through some of those
stories with rachel shabby
and tim stanley good to see you both
let's start with um
the observer should we looking at donald
trump
with that impeachment vote going
in his favor in the last few hours
rachel do you want to kick us off on
that one yes
of course yes so donald trump acquitted
again
the second time um 57-43 was the vote
that came in just now
um only seven republicans turned against
trump
this time round um and it needs a
two-thirds majority of course to impeach
him
um and it is a very dangerous signal
that this is sending of course in the
u.s because
uh signaling essentially that this
incitement
um was was essentially okay
now um the minority speaker
chuck schumer said there is no question
none that president trump is practically
and morally
responsible for inciting what we saw
that terrible scenes in capitol hill
on the 6th of january but was still
acquitted
so what kind of message exactly does
that say when
yes he was responsible but also he's
going to get away from
he's going to get away with it so a lot
of people are saying that this is
putting
uh the us in a very scary position
and the fact that that uh biden is now
president
uh does not mean by any means that the
u.s is out of the danger zone here yeah
well mitch mcconnell that wasn't the
republican senate leader and
it seems extraordinary tim that that you
know
here is a man who voted to acquit
president trump then immediately comes
out and says he was as rachel was saying
practically and morally responsible for
the riot and indicating
there could be a private prosecution
right well okay the counter argument of
course is that the
impeachment should never be brought in
the first place because trump had left
the white house therefore
it was constitutionally just about valid
because the crimes were the alleged
crimes were committed while he was in
the white house
but as he was out of it the trial itself
was a waste of time but
i think the fact that republicans voted
the way they did reminds us that
impeachment is a political process it's
not an ordinary criminal trial it takes
place because the other party
controls the house and can put it
forward to the senate uh and it was
defeated
because the democrats do not have a
two-thirds majority to see it through in
the senate
so in other words it splits pretty much
on party lines
of those seven republicans uh who did
vote
to convict the president um most of them
were either at the beginning of a long
term so so they don't they're not facing
an internal challenge
or they knew their step they knew they
were stepping down
or they were a regular rebel like mitt
romney
so in other words these are people who
calculated that they wouldn't have to
deal
with the blowback from the republican
base of voting to convict
and that's really what is driving
republican attitudes and behavior right
now
is a terror of what happens if i take a
stand against donald trump
i'm going to have to go up against the
base and they're torn because
to some extent the republicans just want
rid of trump now they'd like to move on
they'd like to deal with biden fight
biden on his own terms they'd like to
come up with a fresh candidate in 2024
the last thing they
want is the specter of trump running
again on the other hand
anyone who wants the nomination in 2024
is going to have to win trump's
endorsement
because he he comes out of this trial
still an incredibly powerful man
with crucially a 30 million dollar
war chest that he has built up since the
election under his belt
trump is not going to go anywhere and
he's going to continue to call the shots
and that's is why republicans are
frightened of turning on him
okay let's have a look at things which
are affecting us a little bit more
directly a lot more directly uh the
sunday telegraph
uh looking at um the virus the lockdown
and the
a potential sort of road map out of
lockdown and particularly tim your paper
looking at the pubs issue
yes it's always intriguing what bits of
the
unwinding of the lockdown get leaked to
different papers and so the times is
going with schools uh the mail
is going mostly with pubs we're going
with meeting outside
so as of march the 8th one thing we know
for certain uh is that you will be able
to sit on a on a bench
with someone from outside your household
or you'll be able to go outside
for a picnic with someone from your
household it is also anticipated that a
little bit later
pubs will begin to reopen the big
question there however is around schools
and what the times tells us is that as
of march the 8th it won't just be
primary schools that will be reopening
but all schools
we were reporting that primary schools
were certainly going to open but we were
under the impression that it might be a
week later before secondary schools do
so basically that the government is is
very uh cleverly
leaking little bits and pieces across
all the different papers so that
everyone has something to say
but what it builds up to is march the
8th is that
is the day when things start to go in
the other direction when we start to
unlock
i mean gone through a period of locking
down that's when things will start to
ease up a little bit
it's almost a bit of a dangerous game
rachel isn't it i mean to put a date on
things well
we've seen this time and time again you
know that it's a it's very much
shifting goal post here no i completely
agree
there's a danger here of raising
people's expectations
but it also seems to be an upside down
way of going about it i mean
i agree that there should be an exit
strategy
strategy and goodness knows we're all
fed up
um even even though we we you know
overwhelmingly support the lockdown and
think that it's
necessary but it would make more sense
for the government to say
okay well we will release this thing we
will ease this thing
if by x date um infection figures are at
this number
hospitalizations are at this number that
would make much more sense as a
trajectory and already uh many
scientists are warning
that you know if we ease things too
quickly
or you know just put release too many
things at the same time
we actually run a risk of um going into
another lockdown which of course nobody
wants yeah i mean it's interesting tim
and one of the reports we've
had on sky news today i mean a
restauranteur saying the problem is
he'd rather stay closed than have to
reopen
and then close again because of all the
problems that causes
i i certainly don't think that an indoor
restaurant business
is going to open soon they're going to
they're definitely going to have to wait
for some time well into the spring
the counter argument of course is that
the point of the vaccine
of the vaccine program is to help drive
down
um infections and deaths and those have
fallen quite significantly in the past
week so if they are falling
and if you've got this combination the
lock down in the vaccine then
isn't that logically the moment to which
things should start to ease up shouldn't
they begin to reopen
if not to reopen that's actually not how
it works that's not how it
works it's a fundamental
misunderstanding um it's the vaccine
rollout is is terrific
but the people that we are seeing
hospitalized at the moment
are under 60 i.e the people who have yet
to be vaccinated
so the last thing we want to do is say
well we've got
you know right up to 15 million people
vaccinated which again is brilliant news
but but there will still be the virus
circulating amongst the population
that will still get very ill to the
degree that they need to be hospitalized
everyone knows much of the demographics
people going to hospital
but matt hancock told the telegraph that
we were looking at all adults being
vaccinated by september
so by the logic of that argument that
anyone unders that
people under 70 could catch this and
could go to hospital but the logic of
that argument
we would leave the entire country locked
down until september now plainly no one
wants to do that for economic reasons
educational reasons but also
for health reasons we don't want to do
that as
as we vaccinate and as the cases go down
as the death rate goes down
it should not surprise anyone one that
we will begin to in very small
incremental ways
unlock and perhaps persuade us to
take that risk but my goodness we have
to do it because we can't stay like this
until
the autumn no i completely agree with
you but i think what's missing from this
debate
um is that we just have the government
saying well we're going to release this
we're going to release that and actually
what we need to see
is them saying well given that the
situation really isn't
safe even though we have vaccine roll
out
what is it that we can do a to make sure
that we can ease the situation
in a manner that is safer so have an
efficient test and trace system which we
haven't talked about for a long time
but let's not forget that that was hived
off to the private sector to the cost of
billions
and they bungled it what can we do to
make schools safer so how can we
increase ventilation in schools so that
children can go back in and meanwhile if
things do
seem need to stay shut down what can we
do to protect
people who are suffering the most from a
continuing lockdown
those elements are not brought into the
conversation
i agree with you that we definitely
cannot go on like this indefinitely
but we're not talking about how to make
sure we can we can actually
ease that in a sustainable way well look
we need to leave it there for the time
being you both
raise some very very important points
there
and i know so we're all going to be
thinking about this moving forward
aren't we as to just
when and how we should be coming out of
lockdown and when we want to when we
want to do it as individuals
let us know your thoughts as always but
coming up spare a thought for those
single in lockdown on valentine's day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the wind was like pulling us out of that
little room
[Music]
mandatory evacuation you must leave
i'm greg milam sky's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those wins strong enough to bend and
twist
metal you trying to run me over to
philip no
go away look like it sir
will you respond to those who made
accusations so philip can you go away
i've seen the dark side of america
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart
of america's opioid crisis
[Music]
i've seen heartbreaking human stories
there was a river of blood coming out of
the mosque that's a scene that you don't
forget christchurch has been changed
forever by what happened
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
for the early beyond the risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
safety rage what's monday podcast for
the ones who want to know more welcome
to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free this is the press preview and
we're looking through the papers with
the journalist and author rachel shabby
and the lead writer at the telegraph
tim stanley let's have a look at the oh
we've lost him
never never mind rachel well
you get free reign while we get tim back
on skype uh looking at the sunday
telegraph
and and universities cancel culture
yes this is the story that uh ministers
want to
find universities that supposedly stifle
freedom of speech gavin williamson the
education secretary is set to announce
this policy
and also appoint a free speech champion
and at the same time the cultural
secretary on verdauden wants to
tell heritage bodies and charities um to
defend our culture
whatever that means so it's like a
two-pronged two-pronged attack
um there's been a lot of talk about um
you know council culture and
universities
much of it has to be said whipped up
when the joint
parliamentary joint committee in 2018
looked into this
and its report concluded that there
wasn't really
uh this this phenomenon was not really
going on
um in a way that was being suggested by
right-wing papers such as the telegraph
and the daily mail it's not actually a
thing
um so
you know it it does seem to be very much
a whipped up response from the
government to something that
that that really doesn't seem to be much
of a problem
um confusing free speech with the right
to
you know have a platform wherever you go
student bodies are not
mandated uh to to platform
right-wing people if they don't want to
okay well
it's it's whipped up by the right-wing
media how do you respond to that but
it's someone who we just cancelled and
dropped off the show for a few minutes
you wouldn't cancel me my wi-fi
connection canceled me i'm so sorry i
live in
i live in a sort of a a i'm in a black
spot here i'm afraid
um look we are reporting uh what the
government tells us so it's not a case
of us whipping anything up it's a case
of us reporting for governments
and the government is approaching this
from two fronts uh one
uh is that is going to inform public
bodies that they cannot use public money
for
political purposes i think that's
perfectly reasonable
and the second is that uh student unions
risk
being student bodies risk being fined uh
if they
attempt to take away people's right to
speak i think in both cases what the
government's really trying to do
is to nudge institutions back to doing
the things that they exist to do
uh universities are supposed to be
centers of free speech where people can
speak their
mind and argue and debate and likewise
heritage bodies are supposed to be there
to conserve and preserve culture
they're not there to push a political
agenda especially not if they're
receiving public monies to do it
so really the government's just trying
to get institutions to do what those
institutions are
are there to do well it's interesting
rachel's shaking ahead but
we can't come back in it rachel because
i want to talk about what is the most
important story
frankly for sunday which is the fact is
valentine's day i intend on having
a very romantic 24 hours let me tell you
uh what's scotland on sunday saying
about it all
well it's pointing out that of course
for a lot of people um you know there
are there are millions of um
single-person households across the uk
um so people who are basically stuck on
their own
uh during loc during lockdown and and
therefore will be spending valentine's
day
on their own so the paper is asking us
to to spare a thought
for the population of people who will be
having a valentine's day
with themselves essentially well i i
i've had
45 years of valentine's day is on my own
this year i'm not so
you know i've got the sympathy sorry are
you smooching with anyone tim
no i can assure you this is not the
first valentine's day that i've spent on
my own
but i really but i don't care because on
monday
i am taking the speech of a new puppy so
i shall be very happy thereafter
the 15th is is my red letter day i shall
have my puppy and i shall i shall not be
alone
ever again perfect look really good to
see you both thank you
very much indeed